♪♪
>> Dana: BRAND-NEW TWISTS IN THE
BIDEN DRAMA.
RESURFACED VIDEO SHOWS HUNTER
BIDEN JETTING OFF TO THE
PRESIDENT'S WILMINGTON HOME FOUR
DAYS BEFORE CLASSIFIED FILES
WERE FOUND IN THE GARAGE NEXT TO
THE CORVETTE.
WE'RE ALSO LEARNING THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL ATTORNEY
WHO FOUND THE INITIAL BATCH OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WAS
INTERVIEWED BY THE FBI, BUT THE
BUREAU SKIPPED OUT ON FILING AN
OFFICIAL DOCUMENT 302 TO
SUMMARIZE INTERVIEWS, MEANING
THE FBI MAY HAVE ACTED MORE
INFORMALLY, AND THE DOJ SAYS
THERE'S NO GAG ORDER SO THEY'RE
NOT BEING FORTHCOMING ABOUT
THAT, JUDGE.
>> Jeanine: YOU KNOW, I THINK
JONATHAN TURLEY USED THE WORD
"BREATHTAKING."
I'VE USED THE WORD "STUNNING."
THE DOJ HAS DECIDED THIS IS NOT
GOING TO GO, AND THEY WON'T
FOLLOW THE RULES.
NORMALLY A CHARADE GOES ON THAT
MAKES IT APPEAR THEY'RE
FOLLOWING THE RULES.
THE THEY'RE SAYING, LOOK, LET
THE LAWYER COLLECT THE
DOCUMENTS.
BIDEN'S LAWYER SAID, I DON'T
HAVE CLEARANCE, AND YET HE WAS
GIVEN THE AUTHORITY BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO COLLECT
THE DOCUMENTS.
TIRED OF TALKING ABOUT
TWO-TIERED JUSTICE.
THE BIGGER ISSUE TODAY IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DOESN'T
CARE WHAT YOU THINK.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN GOING TO
MAKE-BELIEVE THEY'RE BEING FAIR.
THEY'VE GOT A GUY WHOSE SON IS
COLLECTING MONEY -- I'M NOT
GOING TO GO THROUGH IT AGAIN --
AND WHO IS UNDER FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION FOR MONEY
LAUNDERING WITH 50 TRANSACTIONS,
NOTICED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
TREASURY, AND THEY'RE BASICALLY
TELLING THE FAMILY, YOU JUST
POLICE YOURSELF.
EVERYTHING IS OKAY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO COME IN IN
THE EARLY MORNING.
TRUMP'S LAWYERS WERE OUTSIDE.
WOULDN'T EVEN LET THEM IN THE
ROOM.
HERE'S THE QUESTION I HAVE,
DANA.
APPARENTLY THAT PENN CENTER WAS
NOT OPEN UNTIL 2017.
OKAY?
THE PENN BIDEN CENTER.
SO IF THOSE DOCUMENTS WERE TAKEN
OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE IN 2016,
WHEN JOE BIDEN LEFT, BECAUSE
THEY'RE OBAMA CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, WHERE WERE THEY FOR
THAT YEAR BEFORE THEY WERE AT
THE PENN BIDEN CENTER?
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
DEFINITELY SOMEWHERE BEFORE THAT
OFFICE WAS OPEN.
>> Jeanine: THEY WERE SOMEWHERE
BEFORE THE OFFICE WAS OPEN.
WE HAVE A DOJ THAT LIED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE FISA COURT.
JOE IS A GOOD GUY, AND THE DOJ
IS SAYING THEY WERE ON SITE.
NO, YOU WEREN'T.
YOU TOLD HIS LAWYERS TO TAKE IT.
IT'S VERY SAD.
>> Dana: JESSE, THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYS THEY CAN'T ANSWER HOW MANY
DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND, WHETHER
THERE'S DOCUMENTS STILL OUT
THERE, WHAT WAS CONTAIN IN THEM,
AND WHY WASN'T THE PUBLIC TOLD
ABOUT THEM.
>> Jesse: IF YOU SAY YOU'RE
COOPERATING, YOU'RE TRANSPARENT,
DOESN'T MEAN YOU ARE.
THIS IS THE HILLARY PLAYBOOK.
REMEMBER HER PEOPLE WERE
SMASHING BLACKBERRIES WITH
HAMMERS, GIVING IT TO THE FEDS.
"HERE, I DROPPED IT."
HAVING THE LAWYERS LOOK THROUGH
IT.
THE REST IS PERSONAL AND FELL IN
BLEACH.
OR THEY INTERVIEW HILLARY, AND
FORGET TO HIT THE RECORD BUTTON.
OUR FBI GUYS ARE BUSY FRAMING
TRUMP.
I'M GOING TO STAND IN THE DRIVE
WAY, SMOKE CIGARETTES, WHILE YOU
LAWYERS LOOK FOR THE STUFF.
I DON'T WANT TO INTERFERE WITH
THE BIG GUY'S OFFICE.
WHAT DID YOU FIND?
UH-HUH, UH-HUH.
DON'T WORRY, I'M NOT WRITING IT
DOWN.
I'LL MAKE IT UP LATER.
THIS IS HOW THESE DOCUMENTS ARE
DIFFERENT THAN THE TRUMP
DOCUMENTS.
OKAY?
HERE'S WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
WASHINGTON.
YOU CAN HAVE THE CHINESE SPEND
THE NIGHT AT THE TRUMP HOTEL,
RING UP ROOM SERVICE, A COUPLE
THOUSANDS, AND THE DEMOCRATS
WENT TO IMPEACH TRUMP ON THAT.
BIDEN CAN COME IN, AND THE
CHINESE CAN POOR A HUNDRED
MILLIONS ON PENN BIDEN CENTER,
GO SOFT ON CHINA, AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE EATING COOKIES
RUNNING AWAY FROM REPORTERS.
>> Dana: HAROLD, WHAT ARE YOU
AND THE JUDGE WHISPERING ABOUT
OVER THERE?
>> Harold: THE JUDGE WAS MAKING
POINTS ABOUT THE DATES IN THIS
MATTER, WHICH I FIND TO BE TO BE
THE MOST INTERESTING THING.
NOVEMBER 2nd AND
NOVEMBER 14th.
FROM NOVEMBER 14th WHEN THE
U.S. ATTORNEY IN ILLINOIS, A
REPUBLICAN, APPOINTED U.S.
ATTORNEY BY PRESIDENT TRUMP, WAS
ASSIGNED TO LOOK INTO THE
NOVEMBER 2nd FINDING.
SOMETHING HAPPENED.
BETWEEN ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND
SAID WE NEED A SPECIAL COUNSEL
FOR THIS MATTER.
WAS IT ONLY OPTICS AND YOU
WANTED INSURE YOU WANTED TO BE
FAIR IN THAT REGARD OR WAS THERE
A LEGAL MATTER?
THE LAWYERS AT THE DOJ SENT TO
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S HOME IN
WILMINGTON TO WATCH HIM DO THIS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
IF THERE WAS SOMETHING FOUND,
THOSE DOJ LAWYERS COULD NOT
INTERACT.
>> Jeanine: THE PEOPLE AT THE
PENN CENTER WHO FOUND IT ALSO
DIDN'T HAVE SECURITY CLEARANCE.
>> Harold: I THINK THE
TRANSPARENCY THING HERE IS
PROBLEMATIC.
I THINK DEMOCRATS WHO DON'T
BELIEVE THIS IS SERIOUS, YOU'RE
NOT BEING SERIOUS.
FOR REPUBLICANS WHO IMMEDIATELY
TRY TO COMPARE THIS TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S MATTER, YOU'RE NOT BEING
TOTALLY HONEST ABOUT THIS.
I HOPE THAT HUR, THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL HERE, AND MOST IMPORTANT
THING IN YOUR INTRO, WHEN YOU
SAID THE DOJ SAID THERE'S NO GAG
ORDER ON THE WHITE HOUSE.
IF THAT'S INDEED THE CASE, I
THINK THERE'S QUESTIONS THAT
WARRANT ANSWERS.
I FEEL SORRY FOR
MS. JEAN-PIERRE, BECAUSE SHE
DOESN'T EITHER KNOW THE ANSWERS
AND OR --
>> Dana: NO ONE IS THROWING HER
A LIFELINE, NOT EVEN THE DOJ.
>> Harold: JACKIE SAYS IS IT
SAFE TO SAY THERE'S A NATIONAL
SECURITY AANALYSIS OR ASSESSMENT
GOING ON ABOUT WHETHER THE
DOCUMENTS POSE A THREAT TO THE
COUNTRY, AND MS. JEAN-PIERRE
COULDN'T ANSWER.
WE DESERVE THESE ANSWERS.
>> Dana: A POINT BROUGHT UP
TODAY, WE ARE AWAITING A
NATIONAL SECURITY ANALYSIS THAT
THE DNI IS SUPPOSED TO DO ABOUT
THE TRUMP DOCUMENTS.
THAT'S NEVER BEEN REVEALED.
BYRON YORK BROUGHT THAT UP
TODAY.
AND THERE'S A REPORT THAT HUNTER
WAS -- THEY SAID THEY CAN'T TALK
ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S FAMILY.
HOW DARE YOU?
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU?
HE'S IN THE GARAGE.
IT ALL MAKES SENSE.
NOW THE PAINTINGS MAKE SENSE.
HUNTER GOES TO THE GARAGE, GETS
THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, SLIPS
IT BETWEEN THE FRAME AND THE
PAINTING, SELLS IT TO THE
ANONYMOUS DONORS FOR HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS.
WHO ARE THEY?
CHINESE.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
HEMMER TOLD ME THIS IN THE
BATHROOM.
[LAUGHTER]
TAKE IT FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH, BUT
HE'S BEEN RIGHT ON ALL OF THIS
STUFF.
HAROLD, YOU SAY YOU DON'T
COMPARE IT TO TRUMP BECAUSE IT'S
NOT TOTALLY HONEST.
HOW DARE YOU COME BACK FROM A
SPLENDID LONG WEEKEND AND SAY
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
JOE WAS AT THE HEIGHT OF
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS, SO HE
DESERVES THE WRATH.
HE WASN'T JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
DOCUMENTS.
HE BLEW IT UP.
THERE WAS FASCISM, A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY, ABOUT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
REMEMBER THAT DARK SPEECH AS
WELL?
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE SHROUD
OF DARKNESS, YOU KNOW, THE
POSSIBILITY OF NUCLEAR CODES,
THE DAMAGE TO SOCIETY.
SO I BELIEVE IN SELF-RIGHTEOUS
RECIPROCITY.
EVERYBODY GETS A FREE PUNCH,
RIGHT?
JOE BIDEN DESERVES A PUNCH FOR
THIS.
>> Jesse: RIGHT IN THE KISSER.
>> Greg: BY THE WAY, THAT'S A
METAPHOR FOR YOU, PEOPLE.
THE FACT IS ALL THE PEOPLE
WRONGLY ACCUSED OR SMEARED, THEY
HAVE A FREE PUNCH.
YOU MAY THINK THERE'S NOTHING TO
THIS.
I DON'T CARE, HAROLD.
PUT THAT IN YOUR TIE.
>> Harold: I SAID IT'S SERIOUS.
I'M NOT DISAGREEING WITH Y